mac versus pc is one of the oldest
rivalries within the tech industry
windows has dominated this race in terms
of market share and will likely continue
to do so moving forward but i think
apple share of this market is about to
grow substantially over the next decade
now many apple fanboys will claim that
it's about time a given that macs were
always better than pcs but i don't think
that's exactly true
we don't have to look that far back to
see how limiting macs were in the past
for example remember how macbooks only
had usb-c ports or how apple shipped
unreliable butterfly keyboards just to
make the keyboard millimeters thinner or
the time that apple recalled 432
thousand macbook pros because they would
catch on fire clearly macs haven't
always been perfect but ever since apple
ditched intel and released their m1
series of products i think apple's
offerings have become more appealing
than ever before and i'm not the only
one who thinks this either as their
annual growth has far outpaced the pc
market
last year annual sales for pcs grew by
14.6 percent while annual sales for the
mac grew by 28.3
or nearly two times as much
also this growth wasn't just amongst
which americans the laptop market or
liberal college students this statistic
was within the global pc market
considering this i don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that apple hit record
mac revenue numbers pulling in over 10
billion dollars within a single quarter
so here's why mac adoption is going
through the roof and why max market
share may grow as high as the iphone's
market share
likely one of the biggest factors
driving up mac adoption recently is that
apple has become more competitive than
ever before when it comes to value
now this may be a bit confusing as we
see apple continuously churn out
extremely expensive products
after all they do sell a 50 000 pc and a
5 000 monitor but how many people do you
really think buy these products
the top-end mac pro is literally
equivalent to the average american's
annual salary and while you may think
that ripping off customers is apple's
entire business plan if you look deeper
into these products you'll know that
this isn't 100 true given that apple
doesn't even take these products that
seriously one of my favorite tests to do
when it comes to expensive apple
products is to see how long it takes
them to ship it to me today is march 27
2022 and if i order the apple pro stand
right now it'll take until april 8th for
it to arrive or 12 days meanwhile if i
order the mac mini it'll arrive in just
two days or i can pick it up in store
today
now if apple was really trying to sell
the pro stand seriously it wouldn't take
them 12 days to deliver it i'm literally
spending 1 000 on a monitor stand you
would think that they would at least
spend some effort in fast delivery but
they don't because they don't take the
pro stand seriously all these products
that people love to make fun of like the
pro stand apple wheels and the mac pro
are all headline products
while a very small number of people will
actually buy these products and may even
find them valuable the primary purpose
of these products is not to generate
sales but to generate headlines like
this
such headlines serve two purposes which
are building exclusivity and price
anchoring the first purpose needs no
explanation when consumers constantly
see such outrageously priced products
they start to associate apple with
exclusivity and desirability and in
terms of price anchoring when people see
a fifty thousand dollar computer they'll
start to think that a two or three
thousand dollar computer is relatively
not that expensive if we put such
products aside noah we'll see that apple
is extremely competitive in terms of
price and value
for example in terms of desktops the m1
mac mini retails for seven hundred
dollars and you can actually get it for
669 dollars at amazon
gary from the everyday dad thinks that
the mac mini is the best value computer
you can buy on the market
m1 mac mini is literally the best
computer that you can buy for the money
if you disagree i challenge you to
comment down below a desktop computer
that's more portable easy to use and
offers more performance for the same
price as the m1 mac mini if we look at
apple's macbook lineup it's exactly the
same case there as well while the
macbook pros aren't the easiest to
justify for the average person just take
a look at the macbook air it starts at 1
000 which makes it the same price as an
iphone 13 pro and if you're a student
you can actually get it for 900
now again you can find plenty of laptops
for 300 to 500
but when you compare the macbook air to
other laptops that are priced at one
thousand dollars it's extremely
difficult if not impossible to find a
laptop that offers more value per dollar
so while apple still doesn't sell the
super cheap entry-level products the
entry-level products that apple does
sell are basically impossible to beat
thanks to the m1
moving on the second reason that macs
have been doing better than ever before
is their synergy there's of course the
apple ecosystem which is getting harder
and harder to escape by the day but i'm
not even talking about that
rather i'm talking about hardware
synergy
one of the top reasons for the success
of the iphone is that apple is able to
leverage so much more power out of the
same hardware
iphones consistently tend to have less
ram less computing power and less
graphics power than their android
counterparts but despite this in terms
of real world performance iphones often
match if not beat these android
counterparts thanks to their hardware
and software optimization the lack of
such optimization was one of the biggest
shortfalls of the mac but that's no
longer the case of course there's the m1
but that's not the only factor take
apple's unified memory for example
several reports and reviews have
suggested that macs with unified memory
not only match but outperform systems
with twice as much regular ram
also it's not just apple that's
leveraging this optimized hardware some
of the biggest software developers are
finally taking the time to optimize the
software for mac adobe for example
claims that their apps are now 80 faster
on m1 max and looking forward it this
energy should only improve as apple
bridges the gap between their ios
devices and their mac devices
historically it developers have not
wanted to develop software for mac
because it's always been such a niche
market something that's not a niche
market though is the ios app store and
with the introduction of apple silicon
on macs software development for ios and
mac os has basically become identical
according to apple themselves most ios
apps require no modification to run on
apple silicon
now this doesn't mean that supercell is
going to develop clash royale for the
mac but what this does mean though is
that software companies who primarily
deal with windows can leverage the large
base of ios developers to efficiently
port over software to mac so in the
coming years apple will not only have
some of the most value-packed hardware
but some of the most optimized software
and the given that this combination is
what allowed them to perform so well
within the mobile market i'd bet that
it'll play out pretty well within the pc
market as well
while apple's synergy and value are
great if you choose the right products
we can't ignore that mac still have a
few major pitfalls starting with a lack
of repairability and upgradability at
the end of last year apple announced
their self-service repair program which
promised to allow consumers to repair
their own iphones and macs with genuine
apple parts but with the recent release
of the mac studio it's not clear how
true apple will stay to this promise
if you guys haven't heard yet if you
crack open the mac studio you'll
actually find that the storage device is
removable and replaceable however what
luke miani found was that if you switch
the slot in which the storage device is
placed or swap the storage device with
another storage device with a different
capacity the mac studio refuses to boot
clearly there's some sort of software
log and or encryption that prevents
users from changing the storage which is
quite stupid i have no idea why apple
doesn't just let people swap the storage
because here's the thing i bet 95
percent of apple customers won't want to
take apart a brand new computer and try
to upgrade the storage so even if apple
allowed this option it these guys would
just pay apple for the extra storage
anyway so it's not like apple would lose
out on much revenue in the meantime they
can avoid all the criticism they receive
regarding lack of repair ability the
second biggest shortfall of max is sort
of related to the first point which is
their base storage options while the mac
mini and macbook air offer great value
in terms of performance they don't offer
great value in terms of storage these
machines should offer a minimum of 512
gigabytes of storage and their higher
end mac studios and macbook pro should
offer a minimum of one terabyte of
storage their current storage sizes are
unacceptable in 2022 aside from lack of
repairability and underwhelming starting
storage the last biggest complaint
regarding macs is their limited software
if you want to play games for example
there's still no reason to get a mac and
i don't think this will change anytime
soon similarly some high-end software
like the autodesk suite have yet to
really be refined for apple silicon
however unlike gaming i think this can
improve in the imminent future as
software companies leverage ios
developers but we'll just have to wait
and see
while macs do still have some shortfalls
i don't think the shortfalls will
actually sway the average consumer that
much like i said the average consumer
won't want to open up their computer
anyway so a lack of repairability slash
upgradability isn't that big of a deal
though it would be nice if apple allowed
for this
and in terms of software limitations
most people will mainly just spend their
time doing work and browsing through
social media and unless you're an
architect or a 3d designer or something
the software limitations wouldn't even
apply to you something else to note is
that all of these issues are relatively
easy to fix
it's not that hard for apple to bump up
the starting storage or light knob on
the software restrictions that prevent
upgrades recently apple has been a lot
more open to feedback given that they
brought back sd card slots hdmi ports
and regular usb ports so hopefully
they'll make these changes as well if
they do make these changes i think mac
adoption will only accelerate moving
forward especially with the launch of
the m2 chip now i don't think mac will
ever become the dominant pc operating
system and just like ios will probably
never become the dominant mobile
operating system however i do think
apple can grow their pc market share
closer to their mobile market share
right now macs only account for about 10
of the global pc market while ios
accounts for 28 of the global mobile
market
due to all the reasons outlined so far
in this video i think it's quite
possible that over the next decade
apple's market share in the pc market
grows closer to 20
this is quite odd for me to say actually
because i've always been a massive fan
of windows due to the versatility and
customizability the first videos on this
youtube channel are actually videos of
me building my pc and discussing the gpu
market it was until recently that i got
my first mac and while i now have the
option of using either windows or mac i
honestly don't think i'll be using my
windows computer that much moving
forward because the mac can do
everything i need but better faster and
smoother and as more people give the m1
a shot i think they'll come to the same
conclusion but that's just what i think
are you guys team windows or team meg
comment that down below also drop a like
if you think apple killed it with the m1
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one